sabéis que dentro de dos años un
ordenador decidirá el precio de tu
alquiler o incluso si eres tú u otra
persona la que recibe atención médica en
un momento dado pues más si eres tú esa
persona idónea para el puesto de trabajo
al que has aplicado o no los ordenadores
toman decisiones sobre nosotros cada día
más frecuentemente en muchas ocasiones
son decisiones sin importancia como el
tiempo que duran los semáforos o la
siguiente sería que ver en hd o sin
embargo muchas otras afectan
profundamente a los derechos más básicos
del ser humano y en muchas ocasiones las
máquinas son muy frías en sus decisiones
por ejemplo una persona de origen latino
es más probable de que pague su alquiler
más tarde que una valija anglosajón por
lo tanto debe ser más más alto el precio
el alquiler o que una mujer tarda menos
en ser atendida por lo que debe tener
piedad en un servicio de urgencia o mi
favorita que las personas llamadas pedro
resumen problemas en mejor medida que
aquellas llamadas mariah éstas
desorbitantes decisiones no son tomadas
por personas sino por un algoritmo
inteligencia artificial que se está
probando actualmente
las máquinas aprenden lo que nosotros
les enseñamos y si les enseñamos mal
será cómo poner nuestras vidas en manos
de un niño malcriado
de hecho nosotros tenemos la capacidad a
tiempo estamos a tiempo y tenemos la
capacidad a día de hoy de cambiar las
tornas y controlar esta situación porque
la inteligencia artificial está bajo
nuestro control sin embargo somos
nosotros los que tenemos que tomar
cartas en el asunto y hacer que la
inteligencia artificial tome decisiones
cada vez más humanas
me llamo marcos tengo 19 años y llevo
cinco trabajando en el campo de la
inteligencia artificial hace diez años
fundé mi primera empresa sobre ello hoy
en día me dedico a diseñar sistemas
artificial que se encargan de detectar
los minerales que robots encuentran en
la luna aunque realmente mis robots no
necesitan grandes clases de ética para
diferenciar entre el basalto y el
lapislázuli
pero trabajar en el campo ha vuelto
sensiblemente impactado por este
problema y por eso vengo a pediros que
vuestra con vuestra ayuda a solucionar
este problema que tanto nos ocupa
he dicho anteriormente que la
inteligente artificial sólo aprende lo
que nosotros les enseñamos sin embargo
esto es la clave de lo que tenemos que
tratar hoy en día los maestros
programadores y la energía artificial no
sólo aprende de sus maestros
programadores como nosotros no solo
aprendemos de nuestros padres también
aprenden en su entorno como nosotros lo
hacemos de la sociedad por eso mismo
nosotros tenemos que establecer una
serie de condiciones o normas que
imponer a los desarrollos de la
inteligencia artificial para que ellos
desarrollen estos algoritmos de acuerdo
a las condiciones y necesidades de la
sociedad
es importante también que nosotros nos
abramos hacia estos algoritmos o usos de
la inteligencia artificial para nosotros
permitirnos que estos sistemas nos
conozcan mejor y que puedan entonces
entendernos mejor y tomar mejores
decisiones pero ver esto de abrirnos
hacia los donadores no suena muy bien
suena un poco extraño porque deberíamos
hacerlo bueno pues primero la
inteligencia artificial aunque la
llamemos así no es muy inteligente
realmente de hecho a día de hoy lo único
que realiza son métodos matemáticos y
procesos estadísticos sin embargo
nosotros realmente lo que intentamos con
el tejido artificial es que aprenda tal
y como lo hacemos nosotros y eso lo
hacemos y lo conseguimos mediante la
propia proporcionándoles datos sobre los
y experiencias y muestras sobre sus
situaciones que nosotros hemos vivido
de hecho el problema que acontece es que
si esas muestras están sesgadas o
nosotros introducimos nuestro sesgos
personales a la hora de entrenar la
inteligencia artificial está tendrás
resultados que también estarán sesgados
o se han impartido o no serán
imparciales
básicamente se puede resumir este
problema en la impacto de dos variables
la variable de la variedad de los datos
que los proporcionamos a los sistemas y
también el tamaño la cantidad de los
datos con los que tratamos en primer
lugar es importante saber que los la
variedad de los datos es de suma
importancia pongamos que realmente el
problema acontece cuando un segmento de
la sociedad queda mal representado o no
está incluido en los datos que
utilicemos para entrenar los sistemas
imaginemos que estamos creando un
algoritmo un sistema que ayuda nos ayuda
en nuestra empresa a elegir a los
candidatos o candidatas que serán los
que tomen puestos en los puestos de
trabajo vacantes si nosotros
imaginemos también que los datos que
utilizamos para entrenar ese modelo la
mayoría de ellos incluyen a personas de
color de pelo rubio pues el ordenador
naturalmente lo que va a inferir o lo
que va a descubrir es que aquellas
personas que tienen el color de pelo
amarillo
realmente son las que son más aptas para
ese puesto de trabajo eso es una muy
absurdo pero realmente es el proceso de
como un ordenador funciona mediante los
datos que les proporcionamos
además
esto no sólo se reduce al problema de
los sesgos o la manera en la que
introducimos los datos o la variedad de
estos sino también que en el propio
proceso de la creación de inteligencia
artificial estamos replicando nuestras
sensaciones nuestras pensamientos de la
sociedad en los sistemas de inteligencia
artificial esto es muy similar a
por ejemplo la situación de un coche
autónomo imaginemos que con este ejemplo
anterior el coche autónomo una situación
crítica tiene que decidir si detenerse
no ante un obstáculo y estamos enfrente
pues un señor rubio y yo que soy castaño
pues no me gustaría estar en esa
situación la verdad
además también tenemos que tener en
cuenta la cantidad de los datos que
utilizamos para entrenar a estos modelos
de hecho la inteligencia artificial
necesita muchos muchísimos datos para
tomar decisiones certeras sobre el
problema que estamos que destaca que
estamos presentando además estas
inteligencias artificiales son tan
sensibles a los datos que es más
importante el hecho de que estos
resultados sean precisos o certeros que
si nuestro sistema es sesgado o es
imparcial
básicamente esto es muy similar a como
nosotros aprendemos porque a fin de
cuentas la inteligencia artificial
aprende en similar medida a cómo lo
hacemos nosotros o incluso como un niño
pequeño un niño pequeño de temprana edad
se cae cientos de veces hasta que
aprende que eso le hace daño la
inteligencia artificial es igual pero
mucho más tonta porque necesitamos
cientos de miles o miles de millones de
muestras de datos para que incluso
comienzan a aprender sobre ese problema
la inteligencia artificial se basa en
encontrar patrones para aprender lo que
es el problema que tienen que resolver
en nuestro caso del ejemplo anterior del
coche autónomo necesitan encontrar
patrones para identificar lo que es o
aprender lo que es un obstáculo
además imaginen cómo de preciso o de
útil sería ese sistema si para entrenar
a ese algoritmo hemos utilizado tan sólo
10 imágenes de personas por muy variadas
que sean esas personas pues lógicamente
en la situación yo seguiría no queriendo
estar delante del coche autónomo porque
probablemente no se detendría a tiempo
por estas cosas digo que tenemos que
abrirnos a la inteligencia artificial
porque realmente esto es la cuestión
importante de resolver un problema de
ética y de moral hay detrás de todos
estos sistemas además no quiero
olvidarme de la otra parte nosotros por
mucho que trabajemos en la inclusión de
datos mucho más variados o muchos
con mucha mayor cantidad nos estamos
olvidando también del control que
tenemos que ejercer sobre el diseño de
estos sistemas porque de nada sirve una
inteligencia artificial que tengo
nosotros entrenados pero sin embargo
está aplicándose en terrenos que no son
bastante éticos que nosotros
consideramos que es una situación que
nos desfavorece
además es tan importante como tener en
cuenta que en el marco ético que
nosotros tenemos en nuestro día a día
para distinguir lo que está bien está
mal no no es de menos tener que incluir
ese mismo marco ético incluso uno más
restrictivo cuando desarrollamos
inteligencia artificial por eso es
incluso más importante establecer los
límites o los marcos en los que estamos
desarrollando la inteligencia artificial
que la propia decisión o la propia
precisión el sesgo de los resultados
además estas decisiones nuevas tenemos
que tomar un grupo de personas en
concreto sino que tenemos que colaborar
desarrolladores investigadores usuarios
y legisladores en conjunto para
establecer ese entorno seguro en el que
la inteligencia artificial se desarrolla
pero aún así tenemos situaciones en el
que la propia aplicación de inteligencia
artificial supone un problema moral y
sin esas situaciones en las que en la
propia presencia de una máquina
realmente es el problema nosotros no
podríamos pensar utilizar la
inteligencia artificial para enfrentar
las vidas de humanos o como por ejemplo
en entornos bélicos o dejar en manos del
criterio determinista de una máquina la
vida de nosotros los humanos
por lo tanto es igual de importante
establecer los límites de la aplicación
de estos sistemas como de conseguir que
sean precisos o conseguir que sean
imparciales
como he dicho anteriormente las
inteligencias artificiales y las
máquinas solo aprenden lo que nosotros
les enseñamos y es en eso que aprenden
la parte más importante que tenemos
nosotros como personas
es la mayor de nuestras
responsabilidades
a través de la mejora de estos sistemas
y de que sean mucho más empáticos con
nosotros y que nosotros les
proporcionamos los datos de manera más
humana podremos llegar a lugares
increíbles resolver problemas que eran
inimaginables en definitiva es esta la
clave por la que la inteligencia
artificial debe ser el futuro no por los
datos o por la tecnología la
inteligencia artificial su precisión y
su investigación está creciendo en
niveles exponenciales es por ello que
tenemos que mantener que si mantenemos
una postura cerrada y privativa sobre la
inclusión de inteligencia artificial en
diferentes aspectos aspectos de nuestra
vida
estaremos provocando un sesgo
individualizar y visualizado y personal
hacia nuestra persona es decir nos
estamos excluyendo de inteligencia
artificial y posteriormente vamos a
tener consecuencias negativas en
nuestras decisiones sin embargo si de
otro modo obtenemos una tenemos una
posición de mentalidad abierta una
presuposición comprensiva a frente al
sistema de inteligencia artificial
conseguiremos que eliminar esos sesgos e
imprecisión que tienen los sistemas
sobre la variedad de nuestro
en traje de artificial sólo aprende lo
que nosotros les enseñamos y entonces
nosotros tenemos que ser los partícipes
de que la inteligencia artificial
aprenda de manera correcta porque
nosotros como personas tenemos cada uno
de nosotros un impacto muy importante en
este problema somos críticos para ello y
con nuestra responsabilidad y nuestra
decisión de tomar las decisiones
correctas a la hora de abrirnos hacia la
inteligencia artificial y contemplar y
aceptar como ésta va a ser desarrollada
es realmente cuando tenemos la
confidencia la confianza de poder hablar
de que nuestros sistemas son mucho más
precisos porque a fin de cuentas cuando
nosotros apoyamos la inteligencia
artificial de manera abierta es cuando
estamos creando a fin de cuentas un
mundo mucho más humano muchas gracias
[Aplausos]